So we just saved our computer program one pass over the entire array. Could we
do this even faster? Could we do it without looking at every single item in the
array? Take a moment to think. Imagine that there's one score that you don't
read. What if that score was the min? If you don't read it, you can't find out
whether it's the minimum or not. We can't find the minimum without looking at
every score. In computer science we would say that we have to do a linear
search. Now what if we knew something more about the elements in this array.
For example what if I knew that all of the elements were sorted from lowest to
highest. Then you wouldn't have to search the whole array to find the minimum.
You would know that it was in the first position. As you continue programming,
you'll learn how to organize your data so you can get the information you need
as quickly as possible. But right now, let's talk more about discovering
algorithms. Back to you, Kai.